if you read anything about bob online
last night if you saw any of the many
thoughts from people who knew him
personally a word that came up a lot
was
uh the sweetest
and
bob was the sweetest he it was the
sweetest man
um
and the reason people wrote that is
because it's true that's jimmy kimmel
getting emotional remembering his good
friend bob saget never imagined that
four and a half years later
we'd be talking about
[Music]
i'm sorry i taped this like 14 times and
i i i just
in a pre-taped segment on mondays jimmy
came alive the late night host was moved
to tears talking about the late comedian
who died unexpectedly sunday after he
was found unresponsive in a florida
hotel room
so last night i was going through emails
with bob and some of them were just
funny but some were very serious emails
about life and
uh
the well-being of of our children and
how hard it is to appreciate one of
those without the other being just right
jimmy had nothing but kind words to
share about bob he says people
gravitated towards him every time he
walked into a room he was so funny and
i'm not talking about
full house or america's funniest videos
or stand-up comedy or movies i mean
funny for real like when you walked into
a party you saw bob and his wife
kelly in the corner you go straight to
them and stay for as long as you could
because he had something funny to say
about everything the tv host also
revealed the full house star was there
for him through hard times in his life
in one email we're talking about her
kids and i have it here
he wrote
one one night soon let's go out and have
some meat and some good damn drinks and
talk about how lucky we are that we have
them
and um we did do that many times when my
son was in the hospital bob checked in a
lot jimmy also talked about the close
bond between bob and john stamos his
longtime pal and full house co-star in
2017 after our mutual friend don rickles
died bob and john stamos who were
beyond friends they were brothers they
are brothers they were like this bob and
john joined me on the show to eulogize
don to tell stories about him and how
much we're going to miss him we never
imagined that four and a half years
later we'd be talking about
i'm sorry i taped this like 14 times and
i i i just
anyway we had a a beautiful conversation
that night the comedian even shared this
hilarious yet touching throwback clip of
the pals in true form i never thought
we'd be friends this long
oh my god the first four years we worked
together we weren't like besties you
were bringing all the hot women in the
world to the show you had a mullet you
were uncle jesse and
i was a married guy in the and living in
the palisades i didn't know what the
hell was going on
you guys are going to be like the old
guys on the muppets
[Applause]
and john he's continuing to mourn his
longtime friend the 58 year old actor
took to instagram on tuesday to continue
sharing tributes to bob quote i'm not
ready to accept he's gone i'm not going
to say goodbye yet i'm going to imagine
him out there still on the road doing
what he loves with all his heart and
humor he's standing on stage killing
another two hour set in front of a
couple hundred of the luckiest people on
the planet they're laughing so hard they
weep john emotionally concluded his post
quote i'm just not ready to say goodbye
yet maybe tomorrow maybe and et has
witnessed that strong connection between
the two actors first hand while
celebrating the 30th anniversary of full
house on the set of the netflix revival
series fuller house in 2017 john and bob
were both clearly happy to be together
again you know every once in a while
you know he knows that my heart and
heart will go like
this is really
this has never happened before on
television i don't think you know and
and the the greatest part is that we
really are making a lot of people happy
every four years there's a new full
house fan born it just keeps
rejuvenating something giving yourself
and we don't see much money from it
really no that's a good part but the
thing that's rewarding is we know that
as he was saying a new full house fan is
born every four years they're actually
literally
in a lot of delivery rooms now while the
mother is pushing the full house is on
the screen and the kid comes out to his
face yeah and this song you gotta do
yeah yeah you sing everywhere you look
um i'm gonna let you guys okay great
awesome i miss you glad
so much
[Music]